les 33 mineurs chiliens bloqués dans
leur mine depuis trois semaines
maintenant ne sont pas prêts de
retrouver l'air libre
prochainement il faudra certainement
plusieurs semaines et même plusieurs
mois pour les remonter le temps de
creuser un tunnel pour les atteindre
en revanche les premières images de ces
hommes coincés 700 mètres sous terre ont
pu être diffusées des images qui bien
sûr ont ému les chiliens commentaire
sarah benhaida une vise envoyé à tous
les chiliens depuis leur refuge 700 m
sous terre les 33 mineurs toujours
bloqués lance un message à leurs
compatriotes sur cette vidéo qu'ils ont
tourné eux mêmes bonjour à ma soeur à
mon père et à tout le monde
merci de ne pas nous avoir abandonnés on
sait tous ce que vous faites pour nous
ils se disent prêts à affronter les
trois ou quatre longs mois d'attentes
avant d'être libéré ils ont déjà
organisé le rationnement en eau et en
nourriture et ils ont même trouvé des
activités pour occuper le temps comme ce
jeu de dominos 700 mètres au dessus de
leur tête le forage d'un tunnel pour les
extraire va bientôt commencer dimanche
ou lundi
en attendant leur seul lien avec la
surface de la terre
ce sont ces tuyaux qui acheminent des
vivres des médicaments ou des messages
depuis 22 jours maintenant les familles
qui comptent sur place sont soulagés de
voir les visages de leurs proches
mais elles attendent des explications le
5 août un éboulement obstruent la mine
les 33 hommes auraient pu s'échapper par
le conduit de ventilation mais la
compagnie qui les emploient n'avait pas
prévu d'échelle pourtant obligatoire
fermé en 2007 après un accident mortel
7000 n'aurait pas dû rouvrir selon les
familles qui porte plainte
ils gagnent des fortunes sur le dos des
mineurs qui ne sont même pas protégés
tout ce que l'on demande c'est qu'il
paye ce qu'ils nous doivent
le gouvernement chilien a fait appel à
la nasa
les conditions de vie au fond de la mine
de san josé serait comparable à celle
des astronautes enfermés plusieurs mois
dans des stations spatiales